SPEAKER 1: Hi, folks, and
welcome to the session
on advanced IAM, where we'll
be covering tips and tricks
around IAM policy management.
I'm Blake, a product
manager here at Google
where I primarily focus on
the Cloud Identity and Access
Management product, which serves
as a central point for access
policy management
and authorization
enforcement across the
Google Cloud platform.
We're here today to dive
a bit deeper than usual
into how you manage
your access policies,
particularly through
the API, as well
as best practices in this area.
We're going to be taking a look
at the policies themselves,
where they can be
configured across your cloud
infrastructure, how,
based on your policies,
Google determines when to
grant access to a user,
different versions
of the policy schema
that are available, and
finally, how you can manage
your policies more
safely by following
some simple best practices.
Let's look at how IAM
policies appear themselves
when you're managing them
through the G Cloud command
line or directly
through the API.
Amongst some other aspects
that we'll get into in a bit,
they're primarily
made up of bindings.
In this example, you can
see the first binding grants
the storage admin role to
an individual user, Alex,
as well as to a
group called Admins.
There's a second
binding in this policy
that grants Bob the
compute admin role.
Roles, of course, are groups
of granular permissions in GCP.
The storage admin
role would let you
create buckets and retrieve or
store objects in those buckets.
The compute admin
role would contain
the permissions to do things
like create VM instances.
So you may have noticed
that the policies only
talk about who can do what.
They didn't indicate the where--
in effect, in what areas of
your cloud infrastructure
they can perform these actions.
That's where policy
attachment comes in.
Your cloud infrastructure
in GCP is organized
in the resource hierarchy.
All of it exists under
the Organization node,
which typically represents
the company you work for.
Under this, you
can create folders
for further categorization,
such as business units, regions,
or environment types.
Ultimately, though, your
cloud resources themselves,
such as the storage buckets,
VMs, or database instances,
will end up being created
and managed in Projects.
Now IAM policies can be
attached to any of these nodes.
The higher they're
placed in the hierarchy,
the more they grant access to.
This is because the effects
of policies inherent down.
Because projects usually end
up being a logical grouping
of resources that represent
a particular workload,
they're a frequent attachment
point for IAM policies
to keep the effect of
those policies scoped
to just that workload.
However, for many
resource types,
it is possible to set
the policy even lower.
You could, for example,
grant a user access just
to a single VM in a project
rather than all of them.
So let's take a look at
how you can set policies
at different levels in GCP.
The policies are
retrieved or modified
through APIs that
are made available
by the service related to where
you want to set the policy.
For example, setting policies
and projects, folders,
or the Organization node is
all done through the resource
manager service.
Or setting a policy on a
particular Pub/Sub topic
would be done through
the Pub/Sub service.
The method to
modify IAM policies
is called setIamPolicy.
Here, you can see it exposed
on the Resource Manager
endpoint for projects or
the Pub/Sub endpoint related
to topics.
But how can you find which
resource types support
IAM policy attachment and
which APIs to call for each?
One good place to start is the
API reference documentation.
Start by looking up the
reference for the service
related to where you
want to set a policy.
Next, find the resource
type upon which
you wish to set that policy.
And lastly, look for
the setIamPolicy method.
Note too, where
this exists, there
will also be a
getIamPolicy method,
which is what you can use to
retrieve any existing policy
attached to that resource.
All of this documentation
is available
on cloud.google.com/docs.
But what if you want
to get a bit fancier?
Google provides an
API discovery service
which itself is an API you
can use to pull information
about APIs that Google
makes available, including
the methods they provide.
Let's take a look at
the listApis call.
As you probably
expected from its name,
it returns a list of
Google APIs you can use.
In the example
here, we're looking
at the compute API entry that
was returned from this call.
This, of course, refers to the
Google Cloud Compute Engine
API.
In its listing, it also
includes the discovery rest URL
for the service.
Let's query that.
In reviewing the discovery
document for a specific API,
you can see all resource
types it exposes
and the methods supported on
each of those resource types.
So for example, we can
see here that there
is a setIamPolicy method
available for OS images,
meaning that you can
set different IAM
policies on different
OS images if you wish.
For you to set the
right policies,
it's helpful to understand
how Google evaluates them
when making access decisions.
Referring back to our
resource hierarchy,
let's say Alice wants to
delete a particular bucket,
called bucket A,
inside of this project.
This is the IAM policy
set on that project.
In it, we can see a binding that
grants Alice the storage admin
role.
So to IAM, what are
our inputs here?
To evaluate, we effectively
need to determine
if a certain principle, Alice,
has the storage buckets delete
permission to be used
against bucket A. To do so,
we need to grab any
potentially relevant IAM
policies in the hierarchy.
This includes
grabbing the policy
on the bucket itself,
the project it's in,
the folder that
project is under,
and the policy on the
organization node itself.
So we have our query, and we
have all the relevant policies
here.
Evaluation ultimately
happens binding by binding.
The default state is
not to grant access
unless a policy
explicitly says to.
Starting at the bucket, we
can see its policy contains
no bindings.
So this policy does
not grant access.
In moving up to the
project, however,
we see our binding from before
that grants Alice the storage
admin role.
Because Alice is
indicated in the policy
and the storage admin
role contains the storage
buckets delete permission, this
binding would grant access.
In continuing, however, we
encounter another binding.
Alice is not listed
in this binding,
nor does the computer admin role
contain the needed permission.
At the folder level,
we see that group Foo
is granted the owner role.
But because Alice is
not in that group,
this binding also does
not grant her access.
This is similar when looking at
the policy on the organization
node.
Alice is neither a member
of the Admins group,
nor is she a member
of the security group.
All that said, the
evaluation decision
here is to allow her
to delete the bucket.
This is because all IAM
bindings are additive.
If any grant access, the
action will be allowed.
Especially when you have a
large amount of infrastructure
deployed to Google
Cloud, it can sometimes
be difficult to determine
whether a user does or does not
have access to perform a given
action on a specific resource.
To help you better understand
and visualize the evaluation
logic we just went
through, Google
provides a tool in the
cloud console web UI called
the policy troubleshooter.
In it, you can enter exactly
the same three pieces of input
we just talked about--
the principle, the
permission, and the resource.
Policy troubleshooter will then
show you the effective access
decision as well as all the
bindings and their effects
in each relevant IAM policy.
This can help you make
adjustments to policies
if the resulting access decision
is not what you intended.
To recap, where you
attach policies matters.
You can simplify
policy management
by setting them further
up in the hierarchy
to grant more access but also
lower down on the project
or on individual
resources when access
needs to be more fine grained.
All bindings are
additive, so it's
important to understand the
bindings you've configured
to ensure you're not granting
access to someone you did not
intend.
Understanding the permissions
in the roles you're granting
and who are members of
the groups to whom you've
granted access as
well as, of course,
who controls the
membership in those groups,
are both important aspects
of making informed policy
management decisions.
And finally, you can
use tools that Google
provides to better understand
the effective state
of your policies.
One more thing before we move
on just because sometimes this
trips people up--
for some types of
permissions, they're
checked relative
to the parent node
compared to where you might
think that they would be.
Let's take the example of Alice
trying to create a bucket.
Here, we see she's exercising
the storage buckets create
permission.
But the resource upon which
this check is being performed
is the project in which she's
trying to create the bucket.
These parent checks
occur on permissions
related to creating
new resources
as well as listing resources
within a certain node.
So particularly for
list permissions,
make sure you're granted
these on the parent container
if you wish for a user
to be able to enumerate
all resources of a certain
type within that container.
Moving on, IAM has
added some new features
since it first launched.
Recently, one such
feature required
us to version the schema of
the policy content itself.
Let's take a look at a
basic policy example.
In February of this
year, though, we
introduced a feature called
IAM conditions, which
allows you to configure when
bindings should apply or not.
Here, you can see a condition
was added to the binding that
states its effect is
only valid for requests
made before January 1 of 2021.
But you might have also
noticed the presence
of this condition bumped the
version field in the policy
from 1 to 3.
When IAM originally
launched, there
were two assumptions baked
into the policy schema.
One was that each
finding included
one role and a list of members,
and in any given policy,
there would only be one
binding for a given role.
Conditions fundamentally
changed this assumption.
Now you could have two bindings
for the same role granted
to different people under
different conditions.
This has an effect on
how you retrieve policies
as well as how you modify them.
When retrieving a policy
using getIamPolicy,
you can specify which schema
version you're requesting.
If you request version three,
it will return the policy
with the conditions
objects included.
If, however, you
specify version one
or do not specify a
version, you will not
receive all the details
of the conditions.
Similarly for
setIamPolicy, if you're
submitting a policy that
includes conditions objects,
you must set its
version field to three.
Taking a look here, if
you ran getIamPolicy
with the requested policy
version set to three
you'll see the
same return we saw
earlier with the
conditioned object intact.
However, schema version
one is requested
for a policy that
contains conditions,
you'll only see an
indicator that there
is a condition on a binding
via a hash concatenated
with the granted role name.
In reality, though,
this is pretty simple.
For existing and future
programmatic integrations
that need to read or
write IAM policies,
just ensure they understand the
syntax and semantics associated
with the version three schema.
Namely, this means your
code should understand
that there can be multiple
instances of the same roll
across bindings
in a given policy
and that some of those bindings
may include a condition.
So as long as this
is the case, you
can always request version
three on getIamPolicy
and set version three
on setIamPolicy.
Finally today, let's
talk about best practices
when it comes to safely
modifying IAM policies.
Critically here is understanding
the get modify set flow.
To modify any IAM
policy, you must first
retrieve the current
state of the policy.
This is done by executing
a getIamPolicy call
against the resource to
which policy is attached.
Once retrieved, your code can
modify the policy in any way
necessary.
For example, you may wish
to add an additional binding
to the policy--
in this case, giving Bob
the compute admin role.
Once you or your code have
made the desired changes,
the entire policy
is submitted back
using the setIamPolicy call.
In this example, that
includes any bindings
that were already there, along
with the additional binding
that you've added.
A common mistake many people
make early on in using IAM
is only submitting their
changes in setIamPolicy
rather than the entire desired
state of the policy inclusive
of their changes.
And any local modification
performed by you or your code
should follow the
rules associated
with the policy schema version
being requested or set.
Another best
practice is ensuring
appropriate concurrency control
is in place for your policy
modifications.
Let's take a look at an example
where Alice and Bob are both
trying to modify a policy
at roughly the same time.
First, Alice
executes getIamPolicy
as the start of her get
modify set sequence.
She or her code then
begin making any desired
modifications to
the policy locally.
Bob then kicks off his get
modify set flow by requesting
the policy currently set and
begins his local modifications.
Here is code then
complete their changes
and successfully set
the updated policy.
Shortly after, however,
Alice's local modifications
are complete, and her
updated policy is set.
This, of course, has a
very unexpected outcome.
Because the basis on which
Alice's local modifications
were performed was the result
of a getIamPolicy issued
before Bob's setIamPolicy,
Bob's changes
were effectively overwritten
by Alice's setIamPolicy.
To prevent situations like
this where two people may
accidentally step on
each other's changes,
IAM supports e-tags to
provide concurrency control.
When retrieving
an IAM policy, it
will include an e-tag
field that represents
the state of the policy
as it exists at that time.
During your modification,
be sure to preserve
this e-tag field exactly as it
was returned from getIamPolicy,
then ensure the same e-tag
is included in the payload
during your setIamPolicy.
If the policy on that resource
has changed since you last
retrieved it, your setIamPolicy
call will appropriately fail.
So to recap, again, always
preserve the e-tag field
all the way through the
get modify set flow.
If the policy on a
resource has changed,
your setIamPolicy call
will fail with an HTTP 409
conflict response.
And in this case,
your client can simply
retry the entire get
modify set operation so as
to incorporate whatever the
latest state of the policy
is into its changes.
While not directly related
to the access management
focus of this
breakout, IAM policies
do contain a field related to
the audit logging configuration
called AuditConfigs.
When performing changes intended
to grant or revoke access,
just be sure not to
drop or otherwise modify
this field, as you may
inadvertently change your audit
logging configuration.
Great, so let's
pull what we just
went through in this breakout
together into a single example.
Here, we have a
Python script intended
to add Alice to a
project's IAM policy,
granting her the
computer admin role.
Note that we first begin by
retrieving the policy as it
currently exists on
the project and doing
so with the requested
policy version of three
because our code complies
with all the rules defined
in the version three schema.
We store that retrieved
policy locally.
Now moving on to the second
part of the Python script,
we can begin our
local modifications.
You'll know that we focus
our change specifically
to the binding section
of the retrieve policy,
simply appending Alice
and her new role grant
to the retrieved policy.
Keeping the changes
focused here safely
preserves the tag and
AuditConfigs fields
as originally retrieved.
Next, because we know
our code complies
with the semantics of the
policy three schema version,
we can go ahead and set the
policy version to three.
While there weren't
any conditions included
on the new binding in
this specific example,
your code will probably
need to accept changes
of many different types.
Some of those may
include conditions.
As a result, any IAM
clients you write
can always express version three
in their set IAM policy calls
so long as the version
three semantics
are always safely followed.
Finally, we submit
the updated policy
to Google Cloud using
the SetIamPolicy call.
Last recap of the
breakout-- make
sure to preserve the e-tag
throughout the policy
modification process.
Only touch the fields
you need when modifying,
and make sure any
programmatic integrations
you develop follow
the assumptions
baked into the version
three policy schema.
And that's all I have for today.
I'd like to thank
everyone for watching.
And if you can't wait to
get even more IAM info,
we have a couple
other great sessions
dropping this week I
encourage you to check out
covering IAM
Recommender and Policy
Intelligence, both
of which can be
invaluable in helping
you achieve least
privilege in your environments.
Thanks again.
Have a great day.